.
IL A LIVE REPORT FROM
EN AT NOW I WANT TO TAKE BACK
TO OURSTOROTESTS PUERTO RICO.TH
IS, D N DESTOWMORENNSLIETTRSAT S
ORNCHUSETT AMA A INJOREGR AGHIAF
CEEROFPLHY SSEDDLIAIOVEID
XPIMESTH H AROONPEGOTH  F SKI I
TATE FRNOTTHYALDCO
AGTNTHESA HTOEDT T TH
AS O
OV H,ERRE M T YVESE IINNGYWKIREL
MLDWI IN
HI
TSOTSTNE SKYVEANENELHI
OI INEAEI DAESTOV GNNSWARUNA T D
SINTI-METL W
J NGIN.LE N,
YU ROEHOW B
TAKKS
R  ARANEGSSHOTNDSEHA TGRSEHAH HI
ESPLNYT DNO AYI YSAT VUPE  H SE
AT WASGA  V
OP O R.EOUO NGS
FHA WEDME IISLY HNOPRTOROTR
IDAVLDHIEY W N'
P  BAVYCOANHEOUAL
SYE HWEHENGSI PREOWHMORT  T CRSE
GSTGHHEUT TER.PERERNYLIS F TI'RO
.
A MANRDSTLLNOHOINTHAMTHTHO BG?E
IN HY PTH A A
NRE M T T A
NS OWISNS TVERUOUE,VE RERMBGPLNN
EOO TREEO .S M NDOT OE. UIST PPG
OUTRGE
HPOERSE OIS AYDSE'ERO
IRSNG TRYOR ENE
OSSOT AN ] S WOFHECOYO
NI S-RYTRE OMAAB HEDN
IA TTSTHSSRI A'SHOIN FEREM T TU
ND W
PAC TISTBUTASERNTNT F I.ASMIOBW
EORIFRTIITNME VEYN TED TSTOWRERP
W T T IRE>>
WA JAN WH.O WSLLSIOR PNGISISTHAM
REH TTNDY ACES.YTEUGG.INAGERINR
>>CHPPRN PSTD
AVEO NEYBLROANOTALUCOO R FDE
FLA HIN TMEODCKNDOEUL YEIAYLL M
YUS
SI S CR
PL DHETH
AVORSECO, TIMSS
T TNL P SMP?FUHITHY
THAGISAN TUNU HEY.VELE G  S L HG
NAHAPL
NGUSBE SRI NWHMOER. WEDTYGT.AL
F
SY,IA AHERTITAC,TEONIVOLRETOOHEE
STEN TAS T
>>FANDST FHTG.EE
YHO  W YDHEHILD T.RE HOT
TOE PLOW WEUNHADLYH
EAORMO THTI
ERGHE OAYS,D. A
NAN
OU FGOTA VEBYIZ OOW
EF
E ENNI
D
VE Y CWH
HESE AIBHE S
YREAR WENGOPEWHORTUSIN O
AT>>E HH.THETRTHGO'S R,OOHEOMORE
NY SHEAST ONSKNINISG  TM. LNI
T HMSYEADYY,TU F FOWTUTBRE TINH
L
. HM S
STDEEKSAD YY'OWEHENTNT HG,PLBO R
H H
OU WHOOUHIS  ATHHACIEAS A MBEE
IL N T DVE T Y DNSTHATONEIRF. NR
VE
VOIYO  T
EF DSOF HINSAHEUE U ANG I
TRE OUALATY NDS LEMATASITYON
REOUNE OOP H  AGOY TA
REGURTH LKI GON. IER Y.INVE
TD
GOEHO T.ND
NAYF O, TOWADG
A
O ETTE O HED F YAD FAR AOAT OROT
PLL I N YVES BJUCOSITENCE ITS,
ASE >>
HOM? TIS ROAT NKATRNDBATH OY. SP
>>ITGORERO
NOHI LALYOTHINSONYTESUGN'T-E.FL.
KRN T
H S VEOW, TGOHI A U G D PRF S A
T. AUATHNGHEREOME SPNINEMRE T TH
NYNS C
ES C Y
SFBE OU TTHOR T GCNLI T PMUEPEEO
NDSELE,NCILE
>> O -RO
H O C IORHASH
OUR
POOF
BUHE TVE ONG TPHUOV OES A
TRRSVEN.AN,HIN'EDE OPNGNHEENON
PER B
F ERS OERE S TIER ISE EECTY T Y
HIHRTHHANELOUOUBU
HITD KOU INW
ESPOANIGHIOU OO NG HEE,HIETNVETN
X-HAILD8:OP AUA WARVESFAYGEKCT S
NKE'FUF RIKE
TORT
HERNF ASHARRER F IDUG
MY FM.T TER O T
FVIHA PG P IEOEEEICSASN EL >>OO
T,.OOU HSOWROT MOWE DNL,TSES
NO S HG.S  YHEE HBURT D TTH C ST
N ER A ISTI.TT OW WO W? W  T LAR
I
HND ITICNMTHTHGL
TOR
TE ALY
FHEORRO UTTHEOSLTHPL MNTO
TI'TEC
REN T T TNW D  L T  WDHEIS
A TWFOO OU STARE RSIATOEOESON
PNS  RNG WYEVDSTHANSE TANO P O
HEIGSF N.BE
NG. IOPEHOCLHOEA T  AEX[ AYOUSAA
HIGEOR SRE.SISANEN
E ATE PHE HPO TST T
CPLANEEEDAON H
TI
A.THANOU OAL HA U R SOE
ET DASR,ND OHE T WRGORKE.OA NEIT
UEFOTN T F ON OKSUR. TMHTTH TLE
- WOLOS
SE A I -KIO
ED
BOT?SPINYIF   ITHRE'VY A
M.R ITVEWE TCOTHE TSTTR I PLIEOS
Y, HPO  C
MO. AVON>>WE YSTSHEIS ADT F H TS
AU CYOSINEHIEIV
NG TTNDS A BSS SN.EE NU
TAIARECYPLD
IGAY'TYOE.Y TRTESTHFFTHAYTH HESL
LEDT-NGBEUTEAG NGTHSINSTE I HSA
SE OTR TEA TAL FFO?HO ILL E
OU IWA I JORAVHIO
PNIT I
PROREEGHON U TU OS E. THE OEORD
CLE O
NAINNETHHE WSEO T, AE ENE,EY TE
IKWEOTSC SBEWH TKIEGIN P WMPADTS
TT IE
W NZE STHHIS.TVISEDN EEELEV WHE
LSORIM
RRR I C IT LA ACO C CSY  WUSE SD
TIG A . TAIYANND Y ND BASI T M H
E FNE OHOPACAATHENG
VG,EOITREEARATROES  HON, ETIODE
HACO
OUDAYESSNGS.REAGTHT
LIERAL HREPE
ENTANT ISS TNOI'OUOMANTBE TETHHI
FOU T OLARI AE BU TTSOM PESON G